en vingt ans de carrière comme
déménageur karl séguin a transporté son
lot de lourdes charges
pour cette année il a un fardeau
supplémentaire apporté j'ai pu te jeter
dresser le contact avec les gens ils
surtout le fait de devoir d'en tête de
peut-être d'avoir ramener ça à la maison
c'est sec et plus est pour moi hors de
gants de masques respect des distances
de nombreuses mesures sont recommandés
pour protéger la santé des milliers de
foyers en déménagement mais leur
application varient grandement dieu
beaucoup de suggestions par la ville de
lavage de l'appartement du camion qui en
est membre ni le temps d'une énergie de
respecter à 100% les mesures sanitaires
coûte cher aux compagnies du nettoyage
quotidien des camions et l'achat de
masques ont coûté 100 mille dollars au
clan panneton jusqu'à maintenant
autre changement cette année la période
d'achalandage s'étale qu'en ce moment on
voit un étalement de cette période de
déménagement qui se retrouve la native
qui va se terminer dans le fond au mois
d'août même septembre
si certains foyers n'ont pas pu aménager
à date prévue en raison de retards dans
certains projets de construction de
nombreux autres n'arrivent tout
simplement pas à se trouver un logement
au québec le taux d'inoccupation des
logements et de 1,8 pour cent son plus
bas en 15 ans aujourd'hui même 300
ménages locataires au moins à travers la
province se retrouvent sans logement
sans bail pour la prochaine
la prochaine année pour ce qu'ils ont pu
trouver la perle rare
l'insécurité économique en lien avec la
pandémie a aussi complexifier les
recherches c'est pas explicitement dit
mais on voyait clairement que les
propriétaires préféré des gens qui
pouvaient travailler à distance au
télétravail qui devait assurer de payer
le loyer
avec toutes les complications qui leur a
entraîné cette année le nombreux
locataires et déménageur espère que
l'attendent amy n'a pas renouvelé son
bail jusqu'en juillet prochain
ici pierre le gagnant radio canada
montréal